hey everybody thanks for jumping over
here to the Q&A we're going to give
people a few minutes here to make the
transition
over and I'll pull Gordon over here with
us thanks so much Gordon we're gonna
give people another let's say minute to
jump
over maybe that's too much 30
seconds but if you're I guess we can
start with some introductions here as
you're jumping over thank you all so so
much for joining us today on this
Wednesday I'm Rachel Dempsey I lead
customer marketing here at posit and
host uh a few different community events
here so always love to see so many of
you thank thanks again for joining us um
Gordon I know you introduced yourself
originally for the demo but do you want
to introduce yourself again here too
sure I'm Gordon Shotwell I'm a software
engineer on the shiny team posit mostly
working on shiny for python
and
Ryan yep hey everybody my name is Ryan
Johnson I'm a data science adviser here
at posit I've hosted a few of these
workflows in the past probably will in
the future but really great to see
everyone again and thanks again Gordon
for a great
demo yeah and thank you Ryan for kicking
these off as well and being the the one
to start these I think we've had maybe
about I think we had seven so far now um
but thank you all for being here in the
Q&A room um as a reminder if you want to
ask any questions anonymously you can
use the slid link and I'll just show
this on the screen right now um but it's
pos.
itemo questions I saw quite a few
questions coming in already during the
demo um I usually save this part for the
end but I want to be better about saying
it up front if you liked what you saw in
the demo and want to do a trial of
workbench or connect
um you can also use a link that I'll
show on the screen here to book time to
chat with our team um and they can send
you an evaluation environment they'd
love to learn more about your use case
um and a lot of times I I just find that
some people don't know that their
companies might already have these
Solutions so if you want more
information on that or to connect with
others within your company feel free to
reach out to me directly on LinkedIn but
I'm going to share a link in the the
chat for you to use too um but thanks
again and I'll jump into the questions
here so one of the first questions I see
over on slido is what are the benefits
of preparing these apis in Python vers
R um so I would say
there's there's sort of the one main
reason which is you have python users
versus our users and that's say the the
main reason you should decide to use one
of the other or you're using a python
Library versus an our our library um so
uh I would say for most data science
applications that's enough basically
it's if you have python users you're
working with python users then having
something all in Python is really handy
like that's one of the main reasons to
use uh shiny for python versus shiny for
R is they're they do mostly the same
stuff but if you're working with python
users it's helpful um the one area where
that's not quite true is in the um API
level so and the main reason for that is
that plumber as an API is a wonderful
tool it's a great way of deploying our
things to an API um but the usage of
plumber for the most part is pretty
small scale um and so as the result it's
hasn't been sort of battle tested at
these like very large or very fast apis
whereas um tools like some of the Python
API tools like Fast API are really
developed around sort of very very high
performance production apis and so you
do end up with um like a lot of benefits
of of you get get a lot of the benefits
of those tools just by using them so an
example of that is the um the way that
fast API does the um data validation so
when you sort of specify like this is
the object type I want to respond want
to accept and I want to give you a 422
error if you're providing like a Json
that's Mal formed or something like that
um that's both like very smooth from a
developer perspective and also like
incredibly technically impressive with
how fast it is um so you're able to
deploy those apis have them be very very
high traffic and and still that type
checking happens extremely quickly um
but I would say for most data scientists
there's no particular difference in
terms of what you're likely to do with
it or not it's mostly are you a python
user or our
user thank you um I will pull a few
questions over from YouTube as well so
you can use the YouTube chat here or you
could use the slider link whatever works
for you um but I see one of the
questions is what is the difference
between host in posit connect and
deploying web apps internally I don't
know if Ryan you want to answer this one
or you want aab
itops sure yeah so um I'm assuming like
hosting them internally you just mean
like hosting them on a web server that
you control and the I think there's a
really substantial difference which is
in terms of compliance and security and
getting those things approved um so when
you're I've kind of worked in data
Sciences in a pretty highly regulated
environment and I think most of the time
when you're trying to spin up a new web
server a new web service an API or
something like that there's a lot of
work you need to do to make sure that
that thing is secure and compliant and
that everybody at your company agrees
with you that it's secure and compliant
and necessary and um that can take
months and months and months to get off
the ground um and so the thing I love
about posit connect both when I was a
user of it before I joined posit and now
as a kind of worker somebody who works
here is that it gives you basically like
a pre-approved space for deploying all
of these different things so that makes
it better both because you know you can
do things faster but it also makes it a
lot more secure because it means that if
there is a security change at your
organization like you you're switching
identity providers or you're going from
password to samle or something like that
that happens in one place as opposed to
having a hundred different web
applications that you're hosting so it
really simplifies things and I think
with data science and these types of
sort of rapid prototyping experiences
it's really a a great tool for that
because it puts it all in one secure
box I don't have much else to add that
was very well said word trying to figure
out why my face is bigger on here than
everybody's trying to fix maybe because
you're the host I don't know I don't
know okay well I think this is as good
as we're getting let's see can I make
Gordon big there we can make Gordon
bigger face
okay I saw a few questions around Sage
maker so I just wanted to make sure we
addressed one of these twoo but one was
we mainly use AWS for our infrastructure
what is the benefit of using posit
solutions for an end to-end workflow and
production in comparison to
sagemaker um yes so that's this is a
really hard question I would recommend
probably talking to somebody on the
sales team to just figure out like your
particular use case and and um and
whether it kind of whether posit
Solutions are helpful or duplicative or
not necessary um one thing I have
experienced is around cost and the way
that the that Sage maker other sort of
managed Cloud Solutions charge you um
which is mostly they charge a markup on
compute so if you're using sagemaker and
you're using like some under some ECU
instance with a particular amount of of
RAM and CPUs you're usually charged I
think 20 20 30% above the AWS rate for
that and that's kind of the convenience
the charging for the convenience of
having those things be managed for you
um whereas posit Solutions all run on a
licensing model um so you're charged by
the number of of users but you can run
it on whatever compute you want if you
have your own server you can run it
there or your own cloud so usually
you're paying from the compute side of
things um uh like a the basic AWS fee
and that fee is also capped which is
nice so if you have one server that's
running connect that means that no
matter what your data scientists throw
at that server like they're not going to
suddenly explode your costs around that
and you don't need to worry about like
you know cost caps and things like that
it's just basically we have the server
we budget it for it you can do whatever
you want there if you outgrow that
server you have to come and have a
budgeting conversation with you know
whoever runs your
infrastructure um so those can be big
deals or not um depending on your use
case um uh one sort of big advantage of
of AWS uh Sage maker is scaling like
scaling things up um is a lot easier on
that system but again this is really
like um context dependent about whether
these things matter to you or not that's
I'd recommend talking to
sales and if it's helpful to add we do
have lots of customers who run on AWS
today but also with regards to stag
maker we have customers running posit
workbench through stag maker as well um
so I did just put in the chat the little
short link I made if you wanted to
schedule time to chat with the team um
because they can go into that in in more
detail
too let's
see um question over from Tyrone in
YouTube
is how do you manage different python or
Cordo versions major and minor versions
on connect is it inadvisable to host
multiple versions would it affect
publishing yeah you should definitely
host multiple versions um so connect
lets you both connect and workbench let
you the administrator basically specify
the same way you can do with r you can
specify these are all the different
python version that you have up there um
the one big difference I think um
between R and python in terms of
multiple versions is that um python it's
really important that the version major
versions match exactly whereas our you
can kind of get away with not quite
matching exactly because our package
ecosystem is a little bit more backwards
compatible than the python one um so
what I have done is basically like you
have a sort of upgrade path for your
team in terms of python where you're
sort of saying like there's a new these
these are the python versions we're
supporting everybody needs to use one of
those python versions when they're
deploying and you have those python
versions also installed on connect um
and then once you if you do that for
both um Python and Cordo it's the same
problem same basic problem um then the
matching will happen pretty pretty well
uh one other really crucial thing for
python is to have people use Virtual
environments when they're publishing um
because basically like what when you
publish something to connect for python
it checks it gets it basically checks
the environment that you're running that
in and if that's like a global python
that you've just installed every package
in the world onto it's going to try its
best to install those because it has no
way of really knowing what you need and
there could be lots of conflicts or just
slow deploys from that so i' would say
like the number one thing is making sure
people use Virtual environments and then
the second one is trying to get some
sort of like upgrade path for your whole
team who's using that system to make
sure that um that they're using a
supported version of python um and just
you need to communicate that and
organize it but it's a helpful thing to
do anyway because um there's not just
connect that runs into problems of
python
versioning thank you um so jumping back
over to slid out there was a
question that was I must have missed it
but how was the custom python package
pushed to posit package manager oh so
this one I actually didn't push it to by
manager because it's a public package so
I could just install it from GitHub um
so for pushing things to posit package
manager there's a number of different
ways um the one that I think is probably
the best one is to have a kind of get
backed um basically get back deployment
to package manager so basically like
package manager is um I think it has a
github's uh Source it's been a long time
since I've done this um and then
whenever you push something to GitHub uh
package manager will will'll pull and
build it um in this case it's such a
small package that and since it was
public it was just easier to have it on
GitHub
um if we have a link to that too might
be helpful Ryan if you would mind
sharing that in the chat too yeah and
that'll give you a lot of the great
benefits of like package versioning and
having it only be installed having
connect set up to install from there
properly so there's a lot of an
advantages of that that system just
didn't didn't quite have time to get it
all set up I see um Michael asked a
question in YouTube as well and it was
any recommendations for alternatives to
pylance and sorry if I don't know that
one yet not having pylance on posit
workbench vs code is a huge pain to the
point I often develop on my personal
machine and then upload to workbench
yeah so um so the basically like U
Microsoft uh which owns vs code has a
number of extensions that are usable
only on the um paid version of V or the
not the paid closed Source version of BS
code and workbench runs the open source
version
um so there's a number of kind of Open
Source type Checkers that are similar I
think the one that most people use is
pyite um but um yeah so it's it's kind
of
um and um I think also yeah like that's
probably the one that I most often hear
about um and shiny live um which is our
uh the um web assembly hosted shiny for
python that uses um pyite for type
checking it works really
well thank
you um so another question over from
slido was you mentioned this setup is
best for proof of Concepts um what are
the constraints of this setup if we
wanted to use it for serving many models
for
production yeah um so there's a few of
them so one of them is and I kind of
mentioned this in the the project read
me I don't think I quite emphasized this
enough on the video which is that that
kind of like endpoint authorization
pattern um that works great to protect
against like mistake or people doing low
wrong thing I wouldn't say that it's
it's reliable against like malicious a
malicious user right so if you were to
publish this to like the world you'd
want to first of all like take out any
of those like the model upload endpoint
have those hosted on some other API
that's that's controlled at the top
level um through something like posit
connect or another Gateway um I would
say there's there's nothing like
technical about that API where you
wouldn't serve it like you wouldn't have
that vs score and this is again one of
the advantages of fast API is that it's
um it's a the API technology is strong
enough to serve a commonly used to serve
very large uh uh intensive production or
workflows I would say the main thing
that I would think about is are you the
person to deploy and host the production
API is your team able to do that um and
if if if yes then that's great you can
you can do it and and work fine but it
often is a like different set of skills
in terms of building an API that can
scale the way you need it to scale can
be cost- effectively run some of those
things are things that often times you
don't necessarily have on your team or
personally um the one other and then
like the one last feature is um I would
be worried about using the same
environment um I think both for
licensing reasons and other other
reasons to use use connect use the same
environment to serve like internal data
products um and and external ones um
both in terms of like just people making
a mistake and Publishing the wrong thing
to the public API when they meant to
publish to the private API and something
getting out there or you know running
into basically like performance problems
if you have like a big spike in usage on
the external one um that's not always
the case but just something I tend to
favor personally is to have just like
separate environments where you can I
mean you can still definitely use
connect we have people who use connect
for um serving large public wasting
shiny apps um or apis like that would
work work fine um but just you would
probably want to have two um to make
sure that that the data sources and
things you were publishing to connect
were were actually accidentally exposed
um that's not necessarily like a
technical thing more of a purse of
people thing of just making sure that
like if you have a database with a bunch
of pii you want to make sure that
connect that the public facing thing
cannot read from that database and you
have a network wall between them because
people always make
mistakes
okay so we have a few is it okay if we
go a few minutes over the top of the
hour okay um so a few more minutes for
questions um and just want to remind
people feel free to use the YouTube chat
if you're comfortable posting there or
you could use the slido link um for the
anonymous questions and I'll just show
that real quickly again this is where
you can find that slido link just so you
have
it uh let's
see one of the questions I didn't ask
yet from slido let me just copy
over not a question I like to ask but I
want to ask every question that comes in
here but one was how would someone
implement this workflow without connect
yeah so I mean the nice thing about um
one of the things I really love about
connect is that connect doesn't have any
um like the the applications that you
deploy to connect are not like special
connect versions of those applications
right so this fast API or this chin app
like they're not special connect fast
apis they're just vanilla connect and
fast API applic or shiny and connect and
fast API applications and so that means
you can host them wherever you want to
so you could do the same workflow with
multiple you know um servers that you're
managing or a single server running
several
processes um the the advantage of that
of course is like you don't have to pay
for the software right you know obvious
the disadvantages I think are um the
like there is a cost associated with
rolling your own stuff and the cost is
you're now responsible for like the
security patching you know and
deployment workflows and that can be
pretty expensive it's just not something
you necessarily pay for right away um
the kind of good example is is that sort
of same one of just your compliance or
Security Group upgrades your the
requirements on what you need to do like
I had an examp experience where my
company was going through this big
process of using a different encryption
algorithm to because of some of the
people we were trying to sell to and
this was an enormous task for all the
services that we had rolled our own but
when we were sort of checking on connect
like connect had already implemented
that in a previous version so it's just
a flag um so it's kind of like I I kind
of think of like these software
licensing tools as a little bit like a
commitment device to continue to upgrade
and Patch your stuff like improve what
it is um and that's the that's the cost
is that you you have a lot more
responsibilities around all the things
that you're hosting and that can be a
really good decision depending on the
team your budget how much you like how
much money you have versus like the
expertise in running those Services um
or it can be a really really painful
decision if you go the other way where
you commit to doing rolling your own
services but then you discover down the
road you have these big security gaps
that you didn't know about and that can
be pretty
difficult
okay let's see one more question over
from slid was Docker and kubernetes were
mentioned in the presentation could you
talk a little bit uh more in detail
about how these Technologies help the
management of the API app yeah so um I
would say Docker um so there's two
pieces of it so Docker is basically a
way of capturing like more of the
environment um so when you do uh connect
deployment connect captures like your
python environment um um but it's
running like all the connect
applications are running on the connect
server so if that has like a particular
system Library installed it's going to
need to use that system Library um
Docker basically lets you have those
things be customized um so it's it makes
your deployment a little bit more like
it's more work because you have to deal
with a Docker file Docker is a little
bit more irritating of a development
experience um but the benefit is that
more of the things like your Linux
version you know your lib curl version
like those things are all locked down to
particular
application um and then kubernetes is a
way of of scaling Docker instances
horizontally so running like many Docker
instances on one or many
servers um and so I would say they kind
of like growth patterns from this would
be what I would sort of say like and um
I think vver does a is a tool which does
a great job of like helping you get
those sort of like basic API Docker
containers written for you um but
oftentimes like it's if you have
something where you have an API it's
pretty easy to put it in into a Docker
container because there's a lot of
patterns of just like how do I run fast
API in Docker and you just go copy that
and point to your API and it works fine
um Docker is a really good solution I
think for passing things on to um a
devops group so if you if you're a data
scientist and you're trying to get
something deployed in production or in
another system you can say to say like
look I have this version running on
connect you can go test it try it out
see how it works and I also have a
Docker file for you so you just need to
go and take this and put it on your
system most things have some way of
running and exposing a Docker um
container so it's a really nice way of
of just doing people's work for them a
little bit and it's not that hard to do
but um if you don't have to use it I
wouldn't I would be my my advice like if
you can have something where it's like
oh yeah I can get this working and
deployed and stuff like that like start
with that and then worry about Docker
when you actually have Docker
problems okay well I think we've gotten
to all of the questions I will double
check if there's any that I missed I
will try and put it with the recording
as well but just want to say thank you
all so much for joining us here today
and for asking all the the great
questions um I want to remind everybody
that we have these events on the last
Wednesday of every month um and so you
can add them to your calendar using this
link shown on the screen POS doit SL
team- demo if you added them in the very
beginning you might have an old event
that's showing so you can delete it and
re and read it but it should add the
event for um every month and Ryan I was
wondering if you wanted to give us a
little preview of like something you're
thinking about for the next
one yeah I mean we're always open to
suggestions on what would be most
helpful from the community uh in terms
of your posi team workflows but uh one
of the things I I think is very
underleveraged underutilized within
posit team is the ability to integrate
with continuous integration uh get back
deployment to posit connect um and so I
think those are going to be some
features that I'd like to cover
hopefully next month or at least very
soon cool well thank you and um I did
just want to add again if you're you saw
this liked what you saw and are thinking
about how you could deploy apis or
models or shiny apps or Dash or anything
you're building with r or Python and
want to try connect um we do offer free
evaluations of connect um so I'll share
this here with you in the chat as well
as on the screen but thanks again for
hanging out with us so nice to see you
all and have a great rest of the day
really appreciate it Gordon thank you
thanks by